je t'aimerai dont on va se battre
tu as raison c'est jamais qu'un cancer
du foie des poumons de la prostate et du
cerveau rien de vital
et si je vous disais que nous avions les
moyens de vous sans vie
vous êtes un combattant on peut vous
donner des pouvoirs au-delà de vos rêves
les plus fous verte vous assurant je
vous demande de tenir vos promesses pour
que je puisse tenir la mienne et le
costume ne faut pas qu'ils soient verts
ni en images de synthèse
la première chose qu'on perd ici c'est
le sens de l'humour
saout au brushing à la victoria beckham
allez quoi tu vas pas blessé tout seul
avec la [ __ ] de service
attendez vous vous demandez pourquoi le
costume rouge c'est pour que les
méchants me vois pas saigner il y en a
un qui a tout compris
il a mis son froc marron ya papa câlins
à terre
amy
ça sent la vioque du smig lige qu'est ce
que tu m'as remonte à une [ __ ] dans la
bouche oh [ __ ] l'enfoiré tu as une
sale gueule comme une couille en dents
de scie non je voyais une carte en
relief du nevada sodomisé à sec par
freddy krueger c'est ça
c
ce soir branlette avec ses singles
toxiques
tu me rappelle un rapport sexuel entre
une courge et un avocat trop mûres merci